the price of a pen increased by 20% and
then increased again by 10% what was the
total percentage increase increased by
20% and then by 10% so the total
increase will be 20 plus 10 which is 30%
as you would have probably guessed it's
not that straightforward look at the
number 100 let's increase this by 20%
first an increase of 20% implies you
multiply this with 1 point 2 and that
gives us 120 now let's increase this 120
by 10% the result will be 1 point 1
times 120 that will be 132 so a 20%
increase and then a 10% increase will
result in a 32% increase an increase of
20% and then 10% can be written as 1
point 2 times 1 point 1 and that gives
us 1 point 3 2 this should tell you that
it is a 32% increase based on these
lines let's try out another one the
price of a pen increased by 20% and then
decreased by 20% what percentage of the
original cost is the current price of
this pen this is interesting increasing
it by 20% and then decreasing it by 20%
does not result in a 0 percent change
that is the first thing you should know
we try increasing the number 100 by 20%
1.2 times 100 is 120 and what will
happen to 120 when it is decreased by
20% it will be 120 times 0.8 which
equals 96 this is the current price but
this is not what we are asked for we
have been asked
what percentage of the original cost is
the current price it will be 96 over 100
times 100 which is 96 percent the
current price is 96 percent of the
original cost a 20 percent increase
would be 1.2 and a 20% decrease would be
0.8 this product will give us 0.96 this
actually tells us two things first 96
percent of the original cost and second
it is a 4 percent decrease and if we
look at the previous example what does
this 1.3 to tell us it tells us that it
is a 32 percent increase and that the
current price is 132 percent of the
original price